Ja.
Schöne.
Töne, dich muss.
Okay.
Ist das immer noch Romario?
Halt, ist gut, dann ich glaube.
Ah, okay, gut, super.
Ja, jetzt gehört er ja, jetzt ist gut.
Und aber, gut, sind jetzt so ziemlich,
ziemlich alle da.
Ich würde einfach starten, wie gesagt,
es ist auch angekündet, dann auch,
also irgendetwas verpasst habt im Nachhinein,
dann nochmal auf der Rumpel dran schauen.
Ich glaube, der Nikola fehlt noch,
aber ich starte jetzt, na, iPhone vielleicht.
Gut, ich starte jetzt einfach weiter,
mach weiter.
Ich habe nur begrenzt,
als hätte ich gerne weitergehen.
Und mache grad
die Hürde.
Ja, mich auch da,
hat man sogar,
wenn niederklar gibt,
wird der auch noch angedeigt.
Also,
reicht, oder mir hat eigentlich alle
Infos,
wo man braucht,
als ganz normale Pilot.
Und auch,
auch, auch,
natürlich,
und unten,
mit weiter im Voraus.
Also,
ich glaube,
ich habe auch noch einen anderen Ger,
wo man noch weiter gehen kann und auch einen anderen Ger,
wo man noch ein bisschen weitergehen kann und auch einen Ger.
Und eigentlich, wie beim Anfang,
immer Gramm auch dabei,
die zwei Wochen berühren,
gibt da oder so, Wolkenbildung,
unabhängig vor der thermischen Entwicklung.
Eigentlich sehr, sehr gut,
sichtbar.
Das ist eigentlich schon alles für Meteorparapor.
Dann,
ich nutze,
tatsächlich
nicht extrem siel.
Es gibt einfach nur paar Sachen,
wo ich bei Görn,
ja, recht gut finde.
Es gibt auch ein paar Sachen,
wo ich denke,
jetzt ein bisschen,
ja, brauche,
wie nicht,
wo machen wir sogar,
und meine richten,
ein bisschen,
die Fülle an Informationen,
denke ich,
macht es, das macht mal auch ein bisschen zu ihm,
übersichtlich,
aber
es ist schon
ganz cool,
was das da alles
bieten hat.
Und auch noch ein paar Auswählen,
welche Map das er öffnen wollte.
Börend,
er Map,
da hat Blätter und so weiter
herauslesen,
auch das sehr gut
und Teilwinde herauslesen,
es kommt immer darauf an,
was ihr da gelöst habt,
was freigeschalten ist
oder nicht.
Was könnte,
da auswählen,
wenn wir jetzt mal rein auf die
Weltprognode,
was ihr für uns gut geschehen,
dann,
ja, wir jetzt dann gleiche mal,
ja,
aber wir sind auch ein bisschen
unübersichtlich,
ja,
dann
diebende Reiz,
der Auswahl,
mit dem wir wählen können.
Also, wenn euch Wolken
und Niederschlag,
einmal am Anfang,
das Gute,
eher unübersichtlich
gestalten,
so wie das jetzt gefallen,
dann könnte das dann
einfach oben links ausdellen,
dann hat das schon mal weg.
Und dann habt ihr da links,
die Höfe den jeweiligen
Win-
mit über 200,
500 Meter übergrund,
was ich gar nicht so schlecht finde.
Ja,
ich habe einen Höhnen,
man durchspielen kann,
mit unten geht,
Age,
mit Ack,
weil ich eigentlich
der Letzig finde,
wo man dann ein bisschen
weiter in die Zukunft schauen kann.
und dann hat da,
und das ist eben noch ganz
wichtig,
da recht
sehr viel Möglichkeiten zu
ausfallen.
Wir können da mal
die verschiedene,
verschiedene der Hintergründe
wählen.
Also, ihr können,
bei euch,
und da ist es halt immer wo auch hingig was er tun halten könnte. Aber was ich jetzt
da cool finde, das sehe die Sachen eingeblendet sind bei mir da die Live-Druckwerte,
das ist immer selber schauen, wo das ist, Meteor-Life, die Veränden, die Veränden,
das sind Sachen, die bei mir jetzt schon mal mit eingeblendet sind, Live-Wind-Werte kann man
mit einem bländen. Man kann da sehr viele einstellen, die gerade machen wird, dann aber auch ein
bisschen zu ungeblich umkönnt, aber wenn er es vielemeldung hat, wenn er es viele eingestellt hat, alle wieder
ausstellen und nach reinholen, was er wollte, was er braucht. Auch da finde ich heiklich sehr cool,
wenn man am Anfang mal ein bisschen weiter rauzumt und das finde ich von weiter draußen her anschaut,
wo hat es wirklich Gebiete mit sehr, sehr starken Wind und wo ist man vielleicht nur ausgeschützt
da oder mit den verbietenen Höhnen auch da dann durchspielen, da sind hier gerade bei
1500 und 2.000 Meter, dann sieht man dann hervorragend, das ist jetzt sehr gut, immer bei Wind ist
sehr gut, aber hier vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen besser, auch meiner sich klarer
dargestellt, mit den Farben noch wieder auslöste, bei Höhnen nicht besser erkennbar, also das muss
man in Bernie leistet, mit den, sehr gut gemacht, man kann wirklich sehr gut so ablöse, gerade bei
Föhnladen, auch bei 2.000 Meter gehen, wird besser ersichtlich und das finde ich schon,
muss ich sagen auch wiederum von der Erstellung her sehr gut, also das muss man im lassen,
das hat er sehr gut gemacht, wenn man jetzt noch ein bisschen genauer rein blicken möchte,
wird auch noch die Prävitems mit eingeblendet, wenn ich drauf blicke, öffnet sich dort unten,
wenn ich sagen muss ich jetzt ehrlich gestehen, finde ich ein bisschen unübersichtlicher, also
es ist nicht ganz so einfach herauszulesen, wo hat es vielleicht eine eher stabilere Schichtung
drinne, also man kann es gut herauslesen, aber ich finde es einfach so vor der Optik her,
finde ich, dass jetzt bei METO Paraport besser gelöst, aber auch hier sieht man halt in den
intensiven Höhen eingestellt, mit dem kleinen Riefung und die Katke auch dort unten dann oder
der Mittelwert für die jeweilige Höhe, man hat da noch die Badeshöhe mit ihnen,
eigentlich auch da wieder sehr viele Informationen, kann oben, wenn man die Wolken
Menge beziehungsweise in den Stockwerk, dass die angeriedelt sind, wie sieht man das,
wenn man ein bisschen Niederschlag aufkommt, aber auch a, kann man sich wirklich sehr viel
im Fuß rausholen, was ich jetzt sehr gut finde an dem Ganzen, jetzt sind wir hier mit
der Temperatur sehr schnell wie der Wienstintate in der Höhe, aber zum Beispiel wir waren 2023 im
Tesin unten, es war wirklich arschkalt, auf 2,200,000 Metern hat es wirklich minus 8,
minus 10 Grad gehabt, auf 2,000 Wands dann glaub ich schon minus 5, 10 Grad und das haben
man da herauslesen können und dann hat man dann auch wirklich in der Luft sehr schnell gefroren,
also das sieht man hier minus 0,1 Grad Temperatur herrscht, also sehr kalt ist, oder? Und
waren in der Wienstintate mit rot gekinzeichen, da sind wir schon auch gut, ich finde es halt
einfach, dass die Fülle an Informationen macht für mich ein bisschen unübersichtlicher,
aber an sich auch kann man sehr viel herauslesen.
Ich bin meine Wissen nur mit einem brechendem Abo, wie gesagt das für euch ist eigentlich der Windwisk und auch
hier könnt auch mit dem Wind wirklich in den vergangenen Höhen fehlen, weil ich finde halt nur
cool sind hier live Hochgrenzen für den Nord- und Süd und Freiening ein bisschen besser aufgekleid,
das heißt für sieben da auch ein bisschen mehr in die Richtung, also dass mich da schon eine ordentliche
Informationen da vorhanden ist und mit dem kann man sich auch gut vorbereiten.
Eine allgemeine Prognose müssen wir schauen, ich würde maximum drei solche Apps benutzen und dann
versuchen herauszufinden welche für euch, vor denen dann noch die zuverlässigste ist und dann
sieht man sehr schnell, was man mit welchem an deinem Ohren gut arbeiten kann.
Wie gesagt, man hat die Möglichkeit den Niederschlag und die Wolken einzublenken und einfach
traufiert, man heißt die Wolke, wir rühren da gelände, das hier ist alles Wolkenverhangen,
das sind es wiederum sehr sehr gut gemacht und an die der Schlagbereiche werden dann logischerweise
hier mit blau grün angekriegt, also hier ein ordentlichen Niederschlag und kann man dann auch noch
Wolkenmenge, Wolken, Höhe sogar herauslesen und den Niederschlag, das sind ich eigentlich
gut gemacht. Wie gesagt, ihr könnt schauen, es gibt vom Burnig, gibt es da jähreste Erklärungen,
man kann extrem viel mit seinem App herauslesen. Ich würde es auch, ich sage mal,
Minimum für euch reduzieren, weil auch da habe ich jetzt die Erfahrungen gemacht, dass die
Prognose, es nimmt zwar das Eichenmodell, aber ich finde die Prognose ist eher auf der deutlich
pessimistisch, pessimistischer dann Seite, also nur mit Burner arbeiten, heißt für mich auch
wirklich deutlich wenig aufliegen und was nicht grundsätzlich verkehrt ist, aber wenn man das
weiß, dann kann man da auch vielleicht noch eine andere Seite mit dazu nehmen und dann hat
man vielleicht doch deutlich mehr Flugtag, also wenn man sich nur mit Burner vorbereitet ist,
meine Ansicht noch ein bisschen zu pessimistet, aber gute Informationen quälte finde ich extrem
wichtig und gut. Wer da noch in Abo gelöst hat, ihr könnt, ich würde es euch nachher noch in T3
setzen, ihr könnt da 10 Franken sparen mit einem Gutscheinquote von mir und auf das jeweilige Abo und
euch grundsätzlich noch mal ein bisschen was ja entsparen, aber auch hier hautdummen, reindummen
wirklich sehr gut, möglich und macht halt wirklich, wie viele Wichter wo hat mehr Wind, wo hat
vielleicht Bereiche mit weniger Wind, die kann ich eher fliegen gehen und was halt hier sehr, sehr gut
dargestellt ist, hier sieht man wirklich sehr schnell mit 1.500 und 2.000 Metern föhnen und macht
wirklich gut sichbar und das finde ich gerade jetzt für den heutigen und beziehungsweise morgen
und die Akkus, ja, mit der die Wönen gewählt ist, ja, ich finde das sehr gut und das funkt
und das ist meine Erfahrung, finde ich sehr gelungen für der Drahtstellung. Gut, das ist so Wind,
Wolken, Niederschlag, mit denen 3 Eps kann man sich da eigentlich sehr gut durcharbeiten,
ihr solltet euch immer auch den Boden, habt es ja bei mir auf dem Eps sowieso, da habt ihr
jeweils die Messung und die Prognose vom Meteorschweif, gerade übereinander liegen, was aus
sehr gut ist, wer aber noch ein bisschen weiter vorausschauen möchte. Da haben wir gesehen,
kann man mit Windy und in Isobaren machen, aber von deutschen Wetterdienst gibt es auch diese Prognosenkarten
und wird unter vom Meteorschweif erstellt, aber dort hat man auf der Seite selbst, hat man die Möglichkeit,
da noch irgendwie in die Zukunft zu blicken und sie hat trotzdem noch nicht nur in Isobaren,
sondern eben auch die zugehörigen Gründen. Es ist eigentlich auch noch ja für mich für meine Vorbereitung
wichtig, da kann ich wirklich bis zu 100 Artstunden in die Zukunft blicken und daher gleich
immer im Hochdruck einfluss oder näher im Kiefdruck einfluss, dann mal weiter auf den Samstag hingehen.
Samstag ist dann durch die Übergangstag, das Sonntag, ich glaube ich nicht so schlecht aus, aber
ziemlich da Gebiete, genau, kann man da eigentlich den Watz unbetrifft oder in den Egen,
was auch in der Analyse da fallenet, das ist immer voll im Hochdruck einfluss, da war ein
sogenannten Pharmatector, zwischen den einzelnen unten hängen wir da quasi fest und das
finde ich eigentlich nur eine sehr coole Variante um deutlich weiter in die Zukunft geblicken,
was jetzt die Bodendruckverteilung angeht und die Groß-Wetternage. Da ist da halt beim
Deuten Wettdruck am Tauen und an Art und die Anleitungen und Analyse und Vorglosen Tat. Ich kann
nicht da den Link direkt in Wotterein, einfach weil es euch dann abbeichen wollen, sind
die eigentlich ganz cool und ist eine sehr gute Vor thereitung. Wie gesagt, die Analyse,
wie die Vorherberechnung von Medioschreit, wo ja auch im Handy hat das ja mittlerweile jeder
Schreit in die Vorherberechnung, Bodendruckkarte, jetzt dann immer für 13 Uhr lokal,
dann nehmen wir sehr gut miteinander vergleichen, das gehört für mich eigentlich auch zur Vorbereitung
mit dazu. Noch diejenigen, die angemeldeten bei mir, auch ein Meteopereich, der auch sehr viel
informationen bietet, unter anderem noch einmal ein anderes Windprogramm, also an das in
dem Besuch eine andere Kalierung hat, vom Tag, nochmal ein bisschen besser, sichtlich,
ob man da jetzt damit noch liegen kann oder nicht. Man seh ich nicht ganz so gut finde,
ist einfach die Grille von Fünferikopauskal, hat hier auch oft gezeigt, dass vier tatsächlich ab vier,
es ist dann wirklich merklich stark geworden und drum denke ich ist vier nach wie vor noch so eine
Grenze, wo man nicht drüber gehen sollte aus meiner Sicht, drum finde ich die Grenze mit Fünferikopauskal,
nicht ganz so glücklich, was aber ein bisschen besser da ist, es fühlt nicht da unten,
und dort müssen wir oben der Realität schon und ein bisschen näher haben, und möchte ich
richtig gut, ich habe da, oder es gibt ein Beispiel von diesen Wetterdiensten, die auch noch
versiedene Diarkamme, ja, da im linken Bereich auch noch wiederflag, ihr habt Wolken,
wo er abrufen könnt. Und was da ganz cool ist, ich denke, sondern kann in Tauer aus, wenn man
da mal kurz draufgehen. Nein, das ist nicht das, was ich wollte, wenn man das an der
E-Viport, ja, auf der Füden ist da möglich, um ihre abrufen könnt und dann habt da, und da
habe ich vor der Niserschlag, da hat ich so einen fein Tauer, da kann man eben so genannten Fünferikopauskal,
auch sehr sehr gut genannten, da dann auf den morgigen Tag gehen, wie man da hat als Fünferinster,
was dann gegen Abend sind, abgebaut wird, also zum Beispiel auch noch etwas, was wir sehr, sehr gut nutzen
können, beim E-Viport. Ja, ich bin gleich da aufgebaut, nur gelb jetzt gewechselt, nicht mehr das
Kosmos, Kosmomo-Modell, sondern das Eikern-Modell, von dem her, muss man da jetzt schauen, sind die
Prognosen sicher wieder ein bisschen, genauerweise, Wolkenmenge, Niserschlag, das hat nicht ganz so
wie die bästliche Front da reinkommt, also ich finde es nicht so schlecht, da fangt es dann
veran, es gibt schon gewisse Ausläufer, da ist dann definitiv der Fall, also es ist auch da nicht
so schlecht für die Vorbereitung, aber man auch auch den Wetterdienst, da haben wir verschiedenste
viele Biogrammen, nicht nur das sogenannte Fündiagrammen, die finde ich eben lästig dort, man hat
dort Event veraus, weil Autentrönen öfter reich bieten, klar, das haben wir so wie du, war eben auch
Wind und Garda sehr, hat sehr gut funktioniert, dann etwas gegen Klowene genutzt, was hervorragend
von uns funktioniert, hat mal Bora Biagramm, das hat mir auch sehr gut geholfen dort unten, finde
ihr also sehr gut und dem ist drei für Frankreich, da kann man wirklich unterversieden den Diagrammen
auswählen und ich finde das halt hervorragend für die Flugvorbereitung, da kann man wirklich mit einem
Blick aussehen, warum passiert was, wenn wir jetzt bei unsauen, wenn man das hier ein Star-Kartogabfall
vorhanden ist, das heißt, da irgendwo kommt dann die Front rein und auch da ist eigentlich für die
Wettervorbereitung sehr sehr wichtig, ich glaube, das hat auch bei mir auf dem App mitgeführt. Gut, was
vielleicht noch so einen Zusatzpunkt, den Niederlag und Wolkenmänge oder Wolkenradar, das schaue ich
da, sich der sehr viel bei Meteor Schweiz auf dem App auf dem Handy, das funktioniert recht gut, auch
da gibt es hier und einmal Prognosen, die nicht dahin kommen, aber Niederlag, Prognose, finde ich
halt da schon sehr gut und gehört für mich dann für den Volketag immer mit rein, aber ich denke,
das können die meisten vom App vom Handy, also das sollte darauf jeden Fall mit reinnehmen in
eure Prognose. Gut, dann würde ich einmal so eine Windprognose schnell mit euch durchgehen,
einmal eine Wolkenprognose mit den verschiedenen Beziehungsweise nur schnell mit Börner, Meteor,
Paraport und Windy und Autark, dann hier noch einen sogenannten Wolkenfahrtab, aber das ist auf dem
Handy besser ersichtlich. Gut, dann würde ich schnell mit Wien die Daten für den morgigen Tag,
aber ja, nehmen wir so weit in die Zukunft, blicken müssen, für den morgigen Tag, wenn ich jetzt hier auf
dem D2, wir sehen allein, ohne dass ich jetzt höhe, aber vom Europäischen, um eigentlich
zwei zum DVD, deutschem Wettlisten, haben wir da, Biber und natürlich auch mal eine ganze andere
Geschwindigkeit, aber 34, das sind immerhin 11 km, und da müssen wir dann jeweilige
Gehöhren, im Moment empfehle ich euch wirklich 3000 Wind gut anzuschauen, an gut nach unten
kommen, durchdächeln, wir haben noch nicht so einen Termikpolster, dass das Ganze sehr gut
abfedern kann, oder besser gesagt, sehr gut nach oben wegdrückt und deshalb immer den 3000
Wind sicher mit reinnehmen, vielleicht fang ich sogar erst einmal noch weiter oben an,
4000 Wind geht noch mal ein bisschen raus und erst nachher wieder in die Tiefe, also da haben wir jetzt
vermogen, auf 4000 KMW Wind gemeldet und 12 Uhr, wir machen jetzt der Einfahrteideheibe, weil nur so um
dem Mittagrum und dann wäre wichtig, dass am Morgen auch schaut, was ist so um dem Mittagrum wirklich
wenn Wind vorhanden, wir haben gewisse Messstationen auch auf 3000 Metern in unserem Gehbumum
abrufen kann und schauen kann, ist das auch wirklich, dann gehen wir da wieder runter, gehen wir da
wieder auf 3000 Runden, die Kriung, 2000, 3000, wie gesagt, 45 KMW, wir sieht, dass wir da unten
im bötig weniger Wind haben, 27 Situettes, aber die Leichtbauffliegbar, bei Füllen auch so
luftseitig, könnte man vielleicht fliegen, wenn es kein Niederschlag hat, wenn der Wind trotzdem
nicht zu stark ist, aber ja, bei so viel Mal hat er unten trotzdem Stau Niedersleger und
das ist nicht so gut, genau, das heißt, so und wenn wir da mal ein bisschen ein Rund
in der 3000 Wind hat im Moment nicht so gut, aber gehen wir mal darunter und haben
einen KMH im Nest, wo man wirklich auch runter und ein KMH sieht, könnte in etwa
was,k.
Ich habe es in den nunten Fächten.
Ich mag gerade auch mit der Pfarrer bohren,
so haben wir es nach 200 Uhr zu morgen.
Da starten wir viel.
Da muss man dann die Sendung gleich nach Hause sehen,
nicht nur unter dem Bereich,
sondern es starten uns nicht an,
die Baume nicht weg,
nicht auch hier.
Für die Uhr auf 2000 Metern die Sendung
war einig.
Die Handwort, die Handwort aus und die Hand in KMH, wind, südwestliche Richtung und dann
wir eigentlich da abweiten Uhr, der stark, dann können wir gerade nennen.
Gut, ok, grundlegend ist man, ok, kommt zacker Wind auf, ich gehe da einfach noch mal
da weiter nach unten, bei Windy, er, bei Metaparapo, als bei Windy.
Dann schauen wir was, wie gesagt, der Börnien, so metropolotische Geben,
und dann so, plant man weiter mit dem Schlavenaut, so mal auf einenhausen Metaparapo,
und dann hat auch einen dran, extra dran, KMH, Wind an, also in sich einig,
das heißt auch wieder, dass das ziemlich sicher eintreffen wird oder mehr, wie sieht
man die Trefferfote, dass das auch passen wird, 13 Uhr, also gleiche Thema,
dann auch das Thema, die auf 3.5 Uhr, das Thema auch, doch stärker.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Und wenn man sich nicht mehr spüren weiß, wenn man sich ganze dann noch gleich mitmitt,
dann hat man die erste, der mit dem Diagramm, immer das da, mir genau,
da der Gramm noch bis, ja, gegen Feten, auch mit dem Abend, wenn man das bei der Wetterfraue
anschaut, dann hat man da noch nicht mehr, aber da sieht man das da,
das ganze morgen, spüren nach dem Tag, sich das ein,
seit da oben, wo kann man das mal rein, gegen Achtung,
und da endlich rein, ist die ganze Zeit, das wissen,
vielleicht auch so aufgebaut, alle drei nebeneinander,
kann man sich für den jeweiligen Tag sehr sehr vorbereiten,
da grobe Prognose wird, ich, also schon auch noch eine Textprognose mit drei nehmen,
so mit dem Schweizer Text Prognose lesen, sind ich schon ein Achtung,
noch mal mit einem mit Läden, ja, ersichtlich, vielleicht kommt Fön auf,
oder es ist jeden Prokwetter, Tiefdruck bestimmt, mit Niederschlag,
Fronten, ich bin oft in Wetterbericht integriert, in der Textprognose,
darum ist das ein Glau immer noch wichtig, dass das noch mit reingenommen wird.
Wetter ist es auch so, ihr solltet schauen, man kann da sehr viel Zeit verbrauchen,
oder benötigen, darum, man muss immer schauen, wenn man schon mit nach oben,
man sich zieht, ja, sondern das Freitag, Samstag ist es ehemig,
dann würde ich sagen, zu sehr im Detail meine Prokose machen,
wenn ich ja was sehe, und dann darf ich mal wieder mit den Sonntag genauer anschauen,
und das natürlich halt am Samstag, am Samstag, also am Samstag,
lassen, den Sonntag inkussieren, haben die okommen,
das kann aber auch sein, dass die Tiefdruck mit Zugung und Druck ist eine lege Flussmeckenflussion.
Natürlich, für die eigene Planung schon mal,
wir müssen sind ja deutlich besser geworden, kann man da drüber,
da sind die Zugung flicken, aber es ist halt doch noch nicht weit,
weil ich glaube, das wird ja dann auch nicht erwarten,
weil wir noch nicht mehr haben.
Das ist noch nicht so viel.
Aber bei Ihnen kann man da nicht in den Freitag,
in den Modell, in den Freitag, in den Modell.
Das würde ich mir manchmal stehen lassen,
wenn ich dann eigentlich von meiner Seite her soweit in Überblick geschaut bin,
also mal für Wind, dann würde ich das Ganze hier schnell stoppeln,
und nachher noch, wer Lust hat, Wolken und Niederschlag anschauen,
auf dem Grab ist offline seit Gäster.
Ja, von Börner sieht man auch nicht,
wir hätten es irgendein Grund.
Ja, da sind eigentlich die Nieder abgebrochen vom Startenwind,
nochiert oder an den anderen technischen Hintergrund.
Aber ich kann es ja aktuell nicht sagen.
Okay.
Also, du bist ja in der Schule.
Und du exakt hier in der Schule.
Und du recognised das.
Und du dich, du macht hier ein Band.
Und du hast die albums in der mal sich gepasselt.
Und zu sein, da ist eine neue Rede.
Du bist wieder in die Schule.
Und sie hat sich in die Schule.
...
s Hier hat sich in der Schule mit den Hand finden.
Du beobaut sich zu sein den Weg zu sein, und ich kann die Hüfte,
Okay, gut, dann haben wir jetzt noch eine Minute.
Das braucht jeder Moment zum Konvertieren.
Und du dann noch mal eine neue Sitzung auf mit Wolken
und Niederschlag.
Und dann würde ich sagen,
am Ende noch weitere Fragen beantworten.
Also dann haben wir es gerade.
Okay, gut.